well let me actually turn this off I
wanted to mention a few open problems
and feel free to also propose your own
problem so the first one is easy to
describe so so this relates to the
entropy inequality that I mentioned
remember that for a mate Royd am so
question one so when we wanted to
basically give a counting algorithm for
a mate weight M what we did was we
maximized the sum of the marginal
entropies so P I plus 1 minus VI veri p1
through PN was in the convex hull of all
of the indicators of basis
and the end result was that this is
basically additive or blank
approximation to the number of bases
so what I didn't tell you about so so
first of all why can't you even like
computationally why can't you why can't
you even compute this it's exactly
because this convex hull is a separable
okay so linear optimization over basis
of Metroid's we can do by the greedy
algorithm and being able to linear your
linearly optimized functions over some
poly tope is the same as being able to
optimize convex functions over the same
poly tope so so you can compute this and
this is an additive of rank
approximation to the number of basis
turns out that this also works
or the intersection of two my choice
so you take your two favorite Metroid's
you look at the convex hull of common
bases and the same convex program you
can first solve it because again the
intersection polytope of two Metroid's
is also separable and and you can also
prove using more sophisticated methods
that this is an additive additive of
rank approximation right so so to give
you an idea of what you can get from
intersections of two Metroid's for
example you can get the number the
number of bipartite perfect matchings in
a bipartite graph so if you have a
bipartite graph and you're looking at
perfect matchings it's exactly the
intersection of two matrix so so your
elements are edges so you're looking at
subsets of edges one mate roid is the
constraint that have degree at most one
so subsets of edges which have degree at
most one at each vertex on the top those
form independent sets of a Metroid it's
like the partition matrix that's m1 and
for m2 you get exactly the same thing on
the on the bottom and a number of
perfect matchings yes
so so if you define your matrix like
this the intersection of these or the
common basis of these two Metroid's I
exactly count the number of perfect
matchings the number of perfect
matchings in this bipartite graph right
so so the fact that you can do this for
any arbitrary to any two arbitrary
matrix is basically a generalization of
this and it's also very much related to
this mandate Vardhan conjecture which
the unit has also proved using real
stability and so on so this is yes so
this gives you an added if so for
bipartite matching x' gives you an
additive of an approximation to the
number of perfect matchings to the log
of the number of perfect matches so so
you get e to the N not the best thing
doesn't correspond to this way
well that was this world example : slice
some of yeah yeah you can show that for
for for bipartite matching is exactly
the same thing but for general Metroid's
it's slightly more complicated yeah so
now it so ok so it begs the question if
you have an arbitrary poly tope over
which you can optimize right you can
still run this convex program right so
so one case which is not captured by
matrices or intersections of Metroid's
is perfect matchings in a general graph
okay so now let's say B is a perfect
matching in a general graph
here G is not a bipartite graph right so
we know how to linearly optimize over
this polytope using very sophisticated
algorithms and you can using those you
can optimize this function still is it
true that this is still an additive of
an approximation to the log of the
number of perfect line it's not do you
have experiments during this or so this
is this is a generation yeah so there is
actually some evidence that this might
be true so so for perfect matchings in
in general graphs there is this
conjecture of lavash and Plummer and
which says that if so basically the
simplest way to describe it is oh I have
these boards so the the simplest way to
describe it is that if G is K regular
and I'm putting more assumptions than
than you need but K H connected
then the number of perfect matchings is
something like k2 the Omega of n there
this is true for so let's say Omega of K
to the Omega of n okay so this is true
the conjecture is for large enough K so
this has been proved for K equals three
that for that when this is when you plug
in K equals three here you get at least
an exponential number of perfect
matchings but the general conjecture for
general case to open and why is this
related to this fact so it turns out
that if your if your graph satisfies
this property being K regular and K is
connected the points the fractional
point one over K 1 over K so on this is
inside the convex hull of all perfect
matchings
so if you--if you compute the so if you
compute the the sum of the marginal
entropy is for this you exactly get an
inequality of that form so that's that's
all so the fact that this conjecture
hasn't been disproved is the only
evidence I have for this being true but
yeah so that's that's one open problem
okay so any which is like Wonderworld
yeah this is basically a generation
event you can think of it as a
generation of underworld and W
stochastic matrices which belongs to the
bullet of the dead man's bullet oh yeah
you can phrase this conjecture in many
many different ways solutely message
successful so in general yeah so so any
anything like lock complete lock
concavity or anything coming from Hodge
theory which works with general graph
perfect matchings I think is of interest
and it might lead to prove some sort of
a proof of this conjecture so say the
cool thing about working kansas
polynomials that you can do the
membership and support okay so here's
the PowerPoint so you have for the
normal given as a black box
okay with some promise like this don't
okay and you would like to check with
that specific monomial
for instance X 1 X 2 X n isn't that
isn't the support yeah you can do it
because it's almost the same as the sub
modular baseball it's upright say it
turns out to be the question is can can
one reduce checking with the exist
matching kills in general yeah so
testing membership in this in this
polytope is is something we know how to
do but we don't know how to do with like
concise linear programs or things of
that sort
so it's a question of great interesting
so the state so so the statement of this
conjecture is that maximize this
objective over the convex hull of all
perfect matchings then the difference
between this maximum and the total
number of perfect match the log of the
total number of perfect matchings is
oven
so this maximum is an upper bound on the
log of the number of my perfect matching
so you have to prove basically a
matching lower bound with an additive
loss of woven so were looking all graphs
all right not bipartite graphs this is
true for bipartite graphs so so the
algorithmic implication of this is that
you get basically an e to the you get an
e to the O of n deterministic
approximation
to the number of perfect matchings
which we currently don't know how to do
there there are randomized algorithms
which achieve this factor but we don't
know how to do with the term I think
Barbara nook has a few results on it it
works for any one for any you take a
Gaussian random fair and square
it gives you if you do it so it there is
a real version that gives you point two
eight to the M and there is a complex
version that gives you point five six to
there but there is no pattern in each
version so okay so yeah so let me let me
mention the second open problem yeah so
this is more of a curiosity at this
point but the question is okay so in
Catalan singer and applications like
Ramanujan graphs and things like that
you really care about the roots of
polynomials right so you have these
interlacing families and you're arguing
about their roots being real and the
roots of the convex combinations being
real can you do anything with la concave
formulas to get results of that form
right so so to make it more concrete
here is a here's a conjecture okay so so
let's say that this is some form of
basically Catalan singer so let's say
that a 1 up to a n R rank one matrices
such that for all I J I is in a PST
sense less than some epsilon 1 times the
sama Valley
okay so this is like the sort of
condition that you needed transition
singer now let's say that mu is a
distribution
and basically subsets of size K of these
and n vectors right and mu is a CLC
distribution and subsets of these and
furthermore you have this property that
probability that each element I is in
some sample from this distribution is
that most some epsilon to
there is it true that the probability
that some of AJ Jeanine s is less than
of epsilon 1 plus epsilon 2 times the
entire sum is strictly positive so the
reason I mentioned this is that Sharon
and I have a have proved this when when
you replace the LC by strongly Riley
here so so the proof doesn't go through
for CLC distributions because you have
to still argue about the mixed
characteristic formula and that palm oil
is basically so you start from the
generating palm you love this and and
the determinant of palm you love these
and both are real stable you do some
operations on them you get the mixed
characteristic polynomial and you prove
that it's still real do that right so
when this thing is CLC the operations
might not preserve real rootedness but
could it still be true that this is
positive so this is this is basically
like you're doing Catalan singer with
like a Metroid constraint if you will
because all you care about is that
something in the support of your
distribution is basically thin risk with
respect to the the wholesome whether it
is one version of this condition single
question
so say you start with polynomial Oh in
the genius of divinity okay which is
stronger okay okay but not necessarily
real step up degree to know are two
variables okay which is not the
caesarian stable world which is do you
have you done any courses okay
so defined now me for two variables
defines this mix polynomial and this
will be removed
actually it will be related by what is
the mix mix applies those operations as
one this product of those 1 plus
derivatives of 1 - yeah so so anyways
and you will get put the number that you
will be removed if you have to it
doesn't you only need non negativity of
coefficients okay so and now the
question is about extreme case of
condition singer so you will get for
phone also strongly awoken key you ask
what what would be the worst case where
you get the worst bound on the maximum
giver and you would in in in a real step
of case it would be linear form to the
power to the power head in the in that
story were concave it's not true so do
you mean I'm not sure if I follow it but
do you want to do you want to come here
and describe
so the mixed polynomial again you start
business for a moment
the mix the mix to twisted phenomena
which respond to this one with the sum M
the sexual lubricant testing this
specific this is a univariate formula in
X yes weights on the first in the word
sir
so it's a sub n whatever the
coefficients of this original so rupee
as summary interest
you take product of one first partial
yes so now I would like you bomb the
maximum again with content if you need
certain relation should be doing
coefficients okay but this is like a
degree two polynomial right so it's
right so you stop yes this is degree two
in this case because when using for any
by barrier and in degree yeah pretty
much like in Ukraine so now you ask what
is divorced from the normal which you
see this another you mean with saturates
up yes so in the oak injection can be
formulated in this way so divorce in
general the worst case in suburban
itself you don't yes
leaner form of mineral form to mean it's
a bunch of which corresponds to automate
seasoning the identity soul anyways in
the strong Yogi's it's not okay for
strongly local cave is this only for
bivariate polynomials yes Burnie numbers
when you get and the reason is
essentially neutral inequalities you can
prove the bound only using you then and
because simple quadratic but anyways but
use use use uniqueness in order to
separate the bomb it's like it's like
saying I see the minimizer of that thing
is a Maximizer that so the Maximizer of
your maximum rule yes assuming bounds on
the traces is unique once again again
it's not Wilson's food and and if you
legs and like this one like
[Music]
yeah it surprised that I feel in real
rooted but you're saying it in general
it's real yeah it was existing normals x
times X minus M X minus one this and you
can do it simple simple calculations or
inequality I mean are there any general
statements about real roots or is
univariate restrictions of these so no
because if you if you think of like a
univariate polynomial which is
completely lock on K we can have roots
in all the places all over the places
so I've plotted for example the
truncation of the Taylor expansion of
the e to the X which is a completely
lock on K formula and if you plot it out
you can see like if you go like that's
if you limit the truncation degree this
is like the complex plane the roots will
be something like this you know that it
was this studied well he proved to take
the Taylor polynomial degree M of e to
the Z okay well its degree air then plot
the roots then contract them for a
factor of n then they converge to the
curve the absolute value of Z
times e to the 1 plus Z equal now the
absolute value of everything equal to 1
I think right and the Z Mexico Douglas
in one yeah let's get him it feels like
you get a curve which which wraps around
the origin and then just by scaling here
you can just map them to any place in
the complex plane but still you can
maybe talk about being above the roots
so being above the roots means that when
you shift your palm you'll by the
corresponding point then you're
basically because they like but there is
a word for space actually one of the
exercises saying something about the
exercise three part one the part we
skipped no no it's not the connection to
the two volume formulas but you do echo
meals are completely a concave if and
only if the when you multiply the
coefficients by the corresponding
factorials you get a lock on cave
sequence no no Shepard's theorem is
saying something stronger that you can
always represent this as a volume
problem yeah so do I have time for one
more
so all right so we skipped the Haj
theory question which is good because
that would have taken a half an hour so
here is one other problem and
so problem three is so it's actually
related to problem one okay so so here
we were doing some sort of a convex
program over the convex hull of a set
right now you can you can sort of ask
what if your set is a weighted set or
you have a distribution which is not
uniform over a set right what is that
what does that even correspond to so it
turns out that you can say something
like this that if you have U is
basically the homogeneous say if you
have G mu which is the homogeneous
testing membership in that convex
polytope you have to replace it by this
that you want to basically find the
maximum over all s of basically a linear
function x is
so let's say that you have an Oracle
which which gets some positive numbers
lambda I right and gives you the set
that maximizes this is the Oracle so so
so you have an Oracle like this that
maximizes these things for you and for
the case of matrix this is just linear
linear optimization over the Metroid
polytope when you take the log of
everything everything becomes linear
right so if you have such an Oracle then
it implies that you you can basically
sorry then you can you can basically
solve an equivalent form of that convex
program and compute M you at chosen
point
up to an error of basically two to the
of the degree so it's a fairly natural
generalization of the metroid case right
so now why am I talking about this so it
turns out that if even if you have an
Oracle which is an approximate Oracle
okay so if you so let's say that you
can't solve this problem this
maximization problem exactly but you can
solve it up to a fraction of alpha then
this alpha just goes through and you get
an alpha times 2 to the O of degree
approximation right so so there is a
problem for which we have some sort of
an approximate Oracle and that problem
is computing the volume of Naruto
so if you have so so let's say that you
have a bunch of convex sets and these
are all for now line segments then the
volume of Z 1 K 1 up to z NK n this is a
completely lock on K follow me oh and
you can expand it out this is basically
the sum over all subsets of if all of
these are in R to the D this is our sum
over all subsets of size D of basically
the absolute value of the determinant of
K iin s times Z to D s
so these are line segments so you can
think of them as vectors when you put D
of them together they have like a volume
or a determinant you can expand it out
like this right so it turns out that
this maximization problem finding a
maximum of these determinants you can do
approximately up to a factor of 2 to the
degree this is because you can maximize
the square of this thing okay which is
the maximum of a determinant all-points
process alright so this is the
optimization problem I showed in the
early in the talk ok
so this goes on this goes true and in
the end you get an algorithm to
basically a deterministic algorithm to
basically two to the O of the
approximate volume of K one of the
Minkowski sum of K 1 through K n which
is what's known as a sonnet all right so
question one is can you can you
generalize this to arbitrary polytopes
instead of so so so let's say that for
simplicity let's say that k1 through kN
our simplices if you if you put a bound
on the dimension of these simplices
there is a there is a there is a trick
that gracefully basically that your
approximation factor basically
gracefully degrade with the dimension
but can you do this for full dimensional
simplices ok so i I have I have no good
intuition of what these coefficients
here look like and whether or not you
can maximize them so why is this
interesting
ok today yes but I don't have a good
intuition for what mixed volumes of
simplicity look like so so let me tell
you why this is interesting
ok so in general when you have a when
you have a convex set in R to the D and
you want to compute its volume you can
either do randomization and do
CMC methods and compute a very good
accurate estimate of it but if you want
to deterministic algorithms there is a
there is a very strong lower bound
saying that
[Applause]
so no deterministic algorithm and do
better than me to do of thee so this is
in the model where you have it just a
separation Oracle for your apology for
your convex set okay now the question is
if you have like if you have a concise
description of the convex set such as
like a Minkowski sum or if you have a
bunch of linear inequalities that which
is scribe a polytope can you break this
barrier and go beyond D to the D and get
something like 2 to the D so that's a so
this is that's that's why it's
interesting and like I said donut ops is
maybe a simple case where you can see
where you can already do this but I
think it would be interesting to to even
see this for for when you have a mix I
mean coffee some of synthesis so there
is also some hope that this might also
generalize so yeah may also work for for
polytopes given explicitly meaning that
so let's say that your polytope is given
as as this thing you have a bunch of
inequalities describing your polytop and
you want the running time of your
algorithm to be polymer in the size of
the input description so the reason I'm
saying that this this this whole theory
might even like extend to the case of
polytopes is that if you take so let's
say this is a polytope P of a and B is a
volume of P of a and B is
la concave formula of B over some convex
cone
so so if you think of if you think of
the polytope described by these
inequalities if you perturb the B's you
are basically moving the facets of the
polytope and there is some region in
which you haven't changed the the poet
or combinatorially no no new vertex has
appeared known no old vertex has
disappeared and so on right so that
turns out to be a convex cone and volume
of this formula is a is a la concave
function over that call it's even
completely la concave when you
generalize the notion of complete la
concavity from the positive or tend to
cones so it would also be very
interesting to compute or you somehow
generalize this machinery to compute the
volume of a polytope given by the set of
linear inequalities within a factor of 2
to the B instead of e to the B which is
itself is exponential simply
exponentially also gets into exponential
yes okay those mixed wardrobes you can
approximate them explain why we need
randomness you need randomness so the
unit has outside unit has a I'm after
exponential yeah but you need randomness
the whole point of this game is to avoid
okay there is a case where you don't
need relevance okay we're already a long
table with those glasses on but those
guys has on the tops of fix of the fixed
number phrase if those guys the
dimensions are yes there's a no tops
which are some of small number oh yeah
so in that case you don't need
randomness and the thing is
the cool thing is the dead stablish
approximates you be so kind of concave
but if you if what you start with is ona
is a zona taupe then minkovski some of
the tops is also a taupe and i we
already know an exponential
approximation for zona tops the whole
point of the game is to go beyond is
very easy you just approximate your zona
soap by an ellipsoid so there are
algorithms where you can basically
produce a an ellipsoid which which
basically went then scaled by a factor
of square root D it
so there is an ellipsoid inside the the
convex set that which that when you
scale it by a square root T becomes an
ellipsoid which contains your poet oh no
no that's for symmetric when you scale
it by D it becomes something that
contains your pollito or convex set and
you just output the volume of the
ellipsoid it's computing that I love so
you can do it in deterministic Ponte
and it's interesting that you can't even
you can't do any any better than that
in the general case
so I think that's it
okay okay so I mean I guess that's the
end of the workshop maybe I don't
it was kind of intense very doing
something about some problems out of it
let's just thank all the speakers
beginning